foreign
thank you
preventative
so I feel like
you're still coming all the way yeah
separation
um
good morning everybody just want to give
everybody a one minute warning
all right good morning everybody it is
nine o'clock welcome to day one of my
data Seattle 23.
are we all feeling energized and ready
for the next few days yeah yeah okay
so I'm just going to introduce our
speakers and then I will turn it over
again
um also at the end I'm going to ask that
we collapse louder so that there's a
competition between the two rooms across
from each other okay let's show some
love
um but today we are here for the next
one hour and 30 minutes to learn about
Automated machine learning and tuning
with clavel
okay you know there's a chance all right
and our speakers are Andreas Moore
research SDK and Microsoft
with microphone
all right I'll turn it on before I do
um of course you all know there is food
available and then I hope some of you
found the restrooms they're also around
and also for questions they have decided
that they'll take questions as they come
up
um so we'll we'll go from there I will
turn it over to them but let's start
with a warm welcome friend
so hi everyone uh thanks for joining our
session uh we're excited to talk to you
about playable uh so Flamel is an
automobile intruding library that
recently came out of our MSR research
research team and it's since been open
sourced I mean I was in a lot of
traction and so we'll cover a few
different topics today
um so we'll start with a brief overview
of automl and tuning for those of you
that might not be familiar and just
really set some context behind what this
you know framework is trying to address
and then we'll kind of go into an
overview of levels and the experiences
some of the apis that are available
through that and then we'll do a deep
dive into one of my personal favorite
topics of how you can parallelize some
of your tutoring and automobile
experiences people and then I guess it's
probably something what also exciting
stuff is we'll go through some of the
newer features that are coming up in
final as well
so uh we'll start with an overview and
so
um again so the session isn't going to
be super if we're there's no like
Hands-On activity right but you can go
ahead and you can download any of these
uh notebooks that they'll presents or
learn more about it for the GitHub repo
we have to work here
um if you have any questions like we
mentioned earlier just feel free to
raise your hands and we'll
get you get your question
so um let's provide some context about
like who is final really for
um so when it comes to flamer we know
that you know from surveys that have
been sent out from even the research
that we've done on the product team for
Azure snaps analytics automl and
hypertuning Hyper parameter tuning are
things that are relevant for both you
know data scientists and software
Engineers but we're also seeing a lot of
Attraction among these kinds of apis
these kinds of Frameworks for
um you know low code no code users
um you really may not have a lot of
familiarity with
automl type of parameter tuning with
they might just be getting started into
kind of their machine learning
experiences but this provides them an
easy way to be able to understand you
know how they can explore different
hyper parameters and how they can kind
of analyze some of their results and so
we think about what flammable is
targeting it's really all of these
different kinds of users and giving them
an easy way to kind of get started with
Machinery or even you know do some more
advanced explorations of new models
and so a lot of you might be familiar
with this so we won't spend too much
time here but
um you know the machine learning
learning workflow has loud steps right
you know everything from getting your
data to Preparing it to figuring out
okay well what side what kind of models
do they want to use how am I going to
train my model to do you know
the test that I need
Ed now we know that these models then
get deployed and that also has its own
set of you know restrictions constraints
challenges
um but we know that in this development
process there's a lot of iteration that
happens
there's a lot of you know trial testing
that goes into approving this this
process
and so for the general developer finding
a machine learning modeling that
requires a lot of decisions
this is everything from you know models
want to use paper parameters you want to
try and even when we take a look at the
models that you want to use it's you
have so many different Frameworks
um and then you know when you've chosen
the framework you then got to figure out
how you implement it how do you train
your data to perform for your desired
task
um you know even along with this there
are a lot of choices to make but even
within that we know that um like let's
say you're starting with a white GBM
model there's a lot of different knobs
and whistles that you have to also
figure out you know what's going to
yield the best model for you
you can explain to things like the
number of estimators the number of leads
your learning rate all of these things
you know depending on how you tweaked it
have a big impact on the results of your
model and so making the wrong selections
can really
you know detract from your overall Model
results and you render your models
eventually effective and so
the real challenge that we see in the
challenge that we want final to address
is how do we help users find these ideal
possible combinations whether they know
what Frameworks they want to start with
or what if they don't but um you know
given ideas that how can we help users
get to
get highly accurate models quickly as we
can
and so this is where flannel comes in
um and so flannel has been designed to
really help users and aggregate all of
these complex decisions and so
um through the rest of this presentation
what you'll see is different ways of
powerful animals helping users
make these kinds of decisions or you
know explore these kinds of questions
we've seen flammable be used across a
lot of different Industries and a lot of
different scenarios we've listed a few
here and so as we go through some of the
demos later today you'll see how flannel
can be used in some of these different
applications as well
so then I'll pass it over to Andreas to
go into a deeper introduction
appointment
this is uh funnel is based on the
research of
um at MSR and unfortunately it couldn't
make it so I'm here to fill in for him
and hopefully do his amazing work
Justice so
um it's a funnel instead of both it's
this research project that where I come
up with new improvements to
um
a high premature shooting in automl
there's also an open source project it's
got a lot of traction and uh
contributions from the community so
there's two main
components that you can use one is the
task oriented rml so this is really
machine learning specific high level
interface it's a second learn like
estimator and you can set a um what kind
of task you want to do like
classification or regression and it will
just do it for you
and the other one is to communicate
function this is
um sender sort of global optimization
interface you can do any kind of
optimization that you want you can write
down the function with any like
parameters or hyper parameters and this
could be an ml function but it could
also be anything else
um
and so
the um behind it is that uh funnel is
particularly um to do optimization fast
and it's very customizable so you have
to use two different layers the more
sort of out of the box automl and do the
different function but both of them can
be highly customized and so you can
um just sort of use the Autumn marble as
it is or you can change what kind of
models you want to do what the time
budget is and
um there's a lot of ways to extend the
API
and so here's sort of the two main
things as I said the automl looks like a
cycle one like estimator you have a
class and you can put in your
configuration and you can call fit and
predict and it just does the automatic
machine learning behind the scenes you
can paralyze this
um
and there's actually like yeah
um different modes you can either give
it a budget in which case it will do
some base neutralization model search or
you cannot give it a budget and that
that will not perform searching just do
a zero short based on
so I'm like how learning
and we'll go into this into more details
soon and the other one is
tuning a user defined function
in
in that case you give it a function here
the name of the function is just the
train lgbm
you give it a metric that says
what um how do you want to optimize it
in this case here that this means click
error and then you give it to the search
space
so the main input for the audio layout
is the task and then the data
for the electrified function you can
give it any function and the search
space and both of them then take the
optimization hacker problems like their
type budget and so on
and so depending on like how much
control you want to have you can do
either a sort of very automated thing or
a very manual thing
so let's dive a little bit deeper into
the task oriented automl
um
so here the idea is that give the
machine learning task and the resource
constraint you want to find the model
that performs very well in that task
so here your input is really in the set
the training data and the task type
and then you just call sort of fit on
the automl class and then you get a
model that you can deploy and so this is
sort of the standard portfolio you're
doing with any machine learning models
instead of using your like grid search
or whatever in second learning you would
just use automl it will tune in
automatically
and it will search over the different
models for you so um it has a built-in
portfolio of like like GBM and second
one based models
um
uh and some deep learning models and it
will search up for them over and
automatically
the
um
they're supported so the
are the same net ones which are like
classification and regression but then
also there's time series tasks which are
quite common so there's a Time series
forecast
um
which is forecasting regression tasks
this time series forecast classification
which is a forecasting class label so
it's a Time series but it's
classification task
um
these are very common but they're
um not part of like most standard automl
libraries there's learning to rank and
then there's several NLP tasks
there's actually we will come to this in
the end there's also specific tasks for
working with large language models and
dialogue based systems
and so for
um
classification regression as I said it
feels like
um start gradient boosting models like
calculus like GBM xgboost it uses
um
cited learn if you're running on spark
it also uses a actually spark terminal
and there's an open source library that
comes from
Microsoft called synapse ml that also
can run both on spark or locally
that also has some efficient
implementations of creating boosting and
some other algorithms
so these are used for tabular datas with
classification regression focus on
tabular data
then for time series forecasting you
again have the gradient boosting models
but also profit Hydro forecasting and
stats models which have more like
hamsters focused um
method and then for you know paid using
second phase Transformers
and so for each of them it has built-in
model civil search over and build a set
of configurations and you just have to
say specify the task and it will do the
search automatically
you can
um
either use this directly or you can
customize this for your use case so
there was someone that wanted to work on
a security domain and they had a
specific classifier and they had
specific hyper parameters and
performance criteria and we'll show in
the demo
how you can customize
the automl interface by providing a
custom model and then still all the
other things will be in place for you
um like how they can split and how the
search is performed and
um but you said you only have to provide
the model in the configurations
so here's the standard sort of automl
loop
that is run so
I said importantly you have the resource
budget that's specified and the task and
then in Gray you can see the machine
learning component which is like you fit
the model and then you predict on the
model
um
and
um in blue you have the Autumn L card
which is
um
selecting the estimators or doing grain
boosting or random forest or linear
models or something and then for each of
them there's the type of parameters
space
um so configurations are sampled from
the estimators and the hyper parameters
the model is trained on them and
then
the loss function determines what uh
estimators and configurations you select
next
and so you can replace any part of this
you can use a custom loss you can use
custom estimators and you can use custom
hyper parameter search spaces
or
um
you can just use all the built-in once
and then you can also
customize how the ml procedure is done
and how the final model evaluated like
if you want to Ensemble the models that
you get average or you just want to use
the best one
and yeah so I walked through this in an
hour a little bit more detail in
um
an example of the flight delay data set
so what we'll do is we all the data set
containing the flexible information so
it's like Airline flight data where you
can whether it's delayed or not we do
this we load the data into pandas
we want to predict the whether the IRA
label and so we'll use the built-in
Autumn out class and first try and do
this with the default model and just see
um
what uh how the results are and then we
can
compare this to using the customized
model
oh
that's it right
okay so um
because we have some
demos that are also using spark we used
the Microsoft Hostess spark offering
um Azure submits analytics
um for which which is a PM
um you can run all this locally
obviously later on if we have different
spark examples you need to run a like a
sort of a spark cluster
um but yeah I'm learning business but
you can all earn your local Jupiter lab
um so we'll start by loading the data
set from openml which is an online
repository of data sets
um we're exploded into training test set
here you can see the data set so there's
an airline the flight number and
Performing two day of the week
time of day and electrical flight
and
as I said so using defaults is very
simple you can just instantiate the Auto
Mount pacifier like you would do a
second one classifier and by default
double Searcher will like GBA and
execute boost cap boost and of course
extra trees and um
linear regression with an L1 penalty
so um
here's a configuration so the things
that we need to provide if we want to do
search is the time budget and
um
uh the metric and then obviously the
task the task and time budget are sort
of domain input and then I'm not going
to run this live
um because we
um we're giving it uh well just two
minutes but still
um we call fit and then it will
um
run its uh the optimization procedure
and so you can see how
the best error uh
slowly decreases over time
and in the end it defines
um
the best estimator is let GBM with
302 estimators 466 leads and so on so if
and
a model for you
with hyperometer settings the best
accuracy in your validation set is
0.675 and the train duration is 5.7
seconds
and if you want you can get the
estimator out
um
if you want to inspect it like look at
feature importances and things like that
and then we can download an hour we just
have the estimator and then we can
upload it up later
and uh
use it for prediction and in production
well not just uh evaluate it on a test
set after we selected the model
and so here we have the an accuracy of
0.67
um
curve of 0.72 and the one class of 60.
um there's also a loss file that we
specified earlier that gives you a lot
of detail about what are all of the
different parameter settings that were
tried and
um whatever the results what are the
runtimes and so on you can look at
and here is the accuracy over time and
obviously it goes back because
for this is the best result so far
you know we'll make sure just to just
get them out right after this okay but
yes it should be it should be
slightly demo I don't know
this is basically just a very simple one
this was just calling Automotive pitch
um
so now I want to compare this uh quickly
to what if we don't tune and so we can
just take a lot of degree on classifier
um or an extra boost classifier and fit
the model and
um
you can see that
they're actually already quite good if
you look at accuracy if you look at
other metrics might be slightly
different but
um you see that the funnel with 10
minutes gives you a slightly better
accuracy on the test set than even extra
boost the logic again
whichever each I like about
um
66 or 66.70 accurate and phenomenal is
67.3 accurate
so as I said every part can be
customized so
um
there's a model called the regularized
brief Forest uh rgf which is not
currently built in so let's say you have
your own favorite model if you want to
use it
um
and it has its own hyper parameters you
can
um write
um a class for formal based on the sqlr
estimator
and you just have to take in what is the
task
and then Define the search space
so certain space is a dictionary of name
where names are hyper permanent settings
and the value the dictionaries and
specified distributions
for having parameter of life
logarithms loginiform
and so on
um
so these are the these are defined
search spaces for the candidates and
once you did that
um
then you can just run the other model
with this so you can hear instantiate
automl you can say ever learner give it
a name and give it the class
um if the settings and now specify as
the estimators this rgf that I've added
as end of our GBM and random Force next
to boost and I run the search again and
now this is included also including the
search space that has specified
so obviously if you add your own learner
you have to add your own hyper parameter
space for all the building owners
there's built-in hybrid parameter spaces
similarly you can write a custom metric
if you want and
um
just specified in a setting as a custom
metric
correct
so this is sort of the basic setup
um
using just the Olympic or class with
different customizations
here's some results
okay
here's some comparison
um against other automl libraries that
are out there automatically learn a high
Advanced duration of a teapot
um
I think this slide doesn't include a
comparison again the one that's in the
other room right now which is auto blue
on but if you look at the newer papers
there's also comparisons against this
and so here uh comparisons always list
the same time budget let's say of 60
seconds uh 600 seconds or 3600 seconds
what are the results of these are all
relative results
um
against Plano so if the um
the numbers that position if it means
performs better given the time
and this is all on The automl Benchmark
so this is the standardized Network
framework
and so
um yeah compared to the other methods
really one of the uh the strong emphasis
of phenomenal is to give you good
results very quickly and so
um if you look at these tank constraints
formula is able to
um
like find better results fast
and it's um as you saw it's very easy to
um
to use so it really minimizes the uh
effort because you can just say this is
my task in here's the data
um
it also does some pre-processing often
is it for you
um I didn't really feel much about this
but it uh
pre-processor support according to the
learner
and so I just mentioned this
um this is using the um if you there's
two versions of this there's a parallel
version in the distributed version
parability version and there's the
single process version a single process
version uses the cost approval hyper
perfect optimization
um also known as the flow
flow 2 algorithm and that's what's used
by default and Powers the search
so um
the other interface is for user defined
functions
um so this is the tune interface
if you compare
that to the automobile provides you more
structure tune basically if you want to
use it for rml you have to implement
more things yourself but it's more
generic so you can use it to do really
anything you like and so you give it
research resource budget search space
and I have your defined function and the
output is the best configuration
um
and so usually defined function could be
model training or could be something
else
so other applications are like
algorithm configuration optimizing
mathematical models
um
or like doing pipelines one thing that
I've been working on around the people
my team have been working on is database
configurations like how do you want to
configure your spark clusters to run
very fast on your workloads so you can
use it for this
so just optimize any function basically
um
do we have time for this do we want to
do today
okay
um so and um
so I want to show then
um how we can use tune with
um again a machine learning tasks that
you can use the other tasks but
um which you know is probably the one
that we're wrongful that's what I'm
familiar with
um
so
okay
back to doing machine learning with the
QR interface
so now
um
yeah
um so what we're doing here is we're
actually
um
yeah we're using
we're loading the data on this bar and
then our unit defined function will be
doing machine learning on spark and
we're trying to optimize the hyper
parameters of the machine learning model
so first we we looked at data set we
created a smart data frame we use a
vector assembler to prepare it for
doing machine learning Spark
we studied the train test data
um
we use the synapse ml just uh
a Microsoft open source library for the
electricity Gam requester
and
um
we Define our user-defined function here
which is a train
which creates the electrician regressor
fits and outputs to model and
developation Metric
so we can just run a train once with
some parameter setting and
um
get an R square so that
this house price prediction so it's a
regression task and so here this is the
resolve using give to the parameters
just during train once and so training
gives us back a score and now we can use
eval sorry tune to
um
uh two and a half parameters
um to optimize this metric
for that we have to
um Define the hyper parameter space so
now because we're basically doing
everything manually you have to say hey
here's um
Alpha organization parameter for let's
be having a learning right number of
leaves number of iterations and
um
could specify the search space using
these
built-in distributions for funnel so
here
we say Alpha is uniform which means zero
and one the learning rate is uniform
between 0.001 and 1 and number of leaves
is uh red and and number of iterations
that are ended in
um so here these are not actually
um like we don't sample here we just
specify the space and so
um these give back objects that are
specified with search space which will
again be searched using search
and um
we Define formal tune which is the
function we actually want to tune if it
takes into config it gets it to train
and then we just return the metric
and then we can call to node run we give
it the function and the parameters and
the time budget
and then it will start
the tuning process
and so
um
if you use human it will actually use an
algorithm called blend search
which uses a
blending of phasing optimization
together with the cost Frugal search
that we saw before
and then you see a little like run all
the trials for you and then in the end
and um
reports
time and our Square
and then in the end you can get the best
config and the best config is this Alpha
learning rate number release number of
iterations
um and now we can use that configuration
in the trade function to see what are
the actual results so
um
untested SF with the original model and
with a tuned model and you can see that
if we tune this live qvm version then we
get go from R square of seven of 0.7 to
an R square of 0.8
so that's quite a big big Improvement on
this regression data set
um so here yeah
at the very beginning for some reason
to one sorry at the very beginning on
the first cell you're doing repetition
to one and really for this
I do
like you learn initial data and then do
it oh
actually I'm not
sure why I mean look looks like it's
just going to be running on one note
right yes
I'm actually not sure if it's oh I think
it's uh it's Distributing the the tuning
so each
I think each each model instance will
run on a different node okay
I think that's the answer
um
but each node will have all the data
because of the smallages left
okay yeah so um again this is in this
case doing on and out but doing it sort
of the more uh manual Way by controlling
everything ourselves and writing our own
learning function and so we could use
the same thing to tune any software
system or
um
yeah optimize this is often also used if
you have uh if you want to optimizing
process that's
um outside of a direct control like if
you want to optimize something that
involve like a real world process say
um
this is used for
like the material signs or pharmacology
where you have to run an extra
experiment to see how well something is
and then you feedback the result
yeah can we try different metrics
um
yes there's actually going to be a site
so
usually Invasion optimization or
application you optimize for one metric
there's actually later on when I talk
about the more recent research here's
something that she worked on that
optimized multiple metrics at the same
time
when in that case you have to give like
a priority like what which metric is
most important to you
yeah and so I mean so tune is basically
um it's more flexible
um interface and you can use it with any
machine learning software or any other
software or like processes in the real
world
um but still you can do very very
technological consequence it will
optimize within the budget constraint
so here um this is sort of an overview
of the different methods that are
actually under the hood so
um
the
flood 2 and constructible optimization
are there two main paper Earth that the
basic algorithm is based on so these are
local search results that are
um
provably efficient so
um compared with other equation
optimization methods or hypothermic
optimization methods these provably give
you
um fast results
but they only do local search so this is
used by default if you use the um automl
um
and then there's one search which
combines a globalization optimization
with local search
and this is used if you use tune or you
use automl on multiple modes
then it spawns different worker nodes
which each do local search which is an
animator combined in global search
there's also online tuning
um and
um
method learning and then
um the method learning if you don't give
a budget to the automl it will actually
do zero shared learning
and um
finally there's the um equal optic gen
which is for tuning large language
models and I'll talk a little bit uh
more about this later
so these are sort of all the different
things that are available in
um
infernal and they all built upon this
flow 2 and CFO and then there are
several layers on top of the CFO
um that add like metal learning online
tuning and
Global search
back two yeah
okay so um in this next section what
we'll do is we'll do a deep dive on some
of the more advanced functionalities
with foil how we can use some of these
things to help better tune our
applications
so we'll start by just providing a high
level overview of the different
constraints that Financial offers
um and so there's three different kinds
of constraints you can set constraints
on
um your overall time budget so your wall
clock time that you want to sign for
your overall automobile experiment you
can also set a budget on different
Constructor arguments right so there's
certain
kinds of fields or certain kinds of
models that you want to be able to tune
and the last of that there's novel
specific constraints in terms of the
amount of time say that you want to
spend too many specific training job or
the time for a model to run predictions
and so
here we have an example of how you can
use Plano to do some more kind of
advanced constraints and provide those
configurations when in your tuning
scripts but let's say you have a automl
task and you want to say you want to
restrict the training time for each
model to be one second you want the
model tab prediction time of a fraction
of a second and then you also want to be
able to combine both the training and
validation less so create your own
custom metric and make sure that that
custom metric will be less than a
particular value so this is one example
of how you can specify all of those
different configurations in flammal
um
in addition Plano also provides a worn
start functionality and so let's say you
have a training job that's been running
for two hours and had the best set of
hyper primer configurations a week later
you want to be able to pick it up and
say Hey I want to restart and kind of
pick up in this automl or this tuning
job and I want to be able to run
additional sets of configurations you
can use the word start functionality to
basically be able to just pick up from
where you started which is a pretty neat
function you know
you're not doing everything in just one
sitting
um the last is around the parallel
tuning and so
um flammal provides spark as an option
for you know paralyzed parallelizing
some of your Automotive
and so there's kind of two different
modes and I think we talked about this a
little bit earlier but the first mode is
that you can do everything sequentially
so um this is particularly helpful let's
say if you have
large spark based models and you just
want to be able to paralyze the tuning
or the automobile experience or those
spark based models that's one case where
you might want to run things
sequentially another example is that you
can also parallelize
parallel lives the individual automl
trials and let's say videos that's small
enough your models are small enough and
you want to be able to run training
across all of your spark nodes or all of
your spark executors you can do that
just using um
spark as well so a few different ways of
how you can kind of optimize your
training time if you're using spark you
have a few different constraints or I
guess configurations that you can tweak
and so
um similar to the you know SK learn you
can specify the number of jobs and so
this will be how many cores you want to
allocate for each training job you can
also say have a parallel trials you
might want to run and so by default
spark will run one
trial per executor but you can also
customize this as well
and so in this next example what we'll
see is how we can read a spark data set
and we'll use spark to kind of do all
the ETL for it and then we'll train a
snap smell like GBM mom so again kind of
similar to some of the tuning example
that we saw this is a spark based model
that will then tune
um and we'll see how even on this tuning
example we can boost our accuracy or as
being z-sport and then we'll also do
some other kind of comparisons where we
can run flammal automl on the spark data
set and
we'll use it to kind of do a search of
spark based Learners and we can also use
Primal and Spark to parallelize these
automotrops a lot of different
combinations that we'll see
um so let me just jump over
so um yeah so as I mentioned in this
example we'll see is how we can use snap
SML flannel and Spark all together
um and so I'll just go through so here
we're going to start by just loading our
data in this case we're going to be
working with a bankruptcy data set and
so yeah this contains a bunch of
information on
companies operating gross margin profit
rates Etc
we'll then generate our training and
test sets with spark and then we'll use
some of the spark featureizers to
basically transform our data set and
generate our training data
um
then we'll start with setting up our
default snap small light gdm model
again this is like one of our smart
based models so we'll see how we can use
that later on and then we'll just Define
our
we'll use our default model and generate
our kind of default metrics so we can
kind of come up with our Baseline
um
so here we can see we have an AUC of
about 0.66
and so the next piece is we'll run our
flammal tune and so here we have
specified our training function and
we'll specify all the different places
that we want to search over and so here
we'll explore things around learning
rates number of leads number of
iterations and we'll use AZ as kind of
our metric that we want to optimize
against
um and so in this example
um
I've just provided some simple
constraints but basically what we'll be
able to see as we find tuning we'll get
back our optimal model and we'll see
that our optimized ABC score is around
like 0.81
um but the thing that I wanted to
highlight here is here we're able to
take our spark data set feed that into
our tuning and we don't we're not
restricted to work with you know
specific you know kind of data frame you
can also kind of support spark in this
example and then also see how you can
work with some of the spark based
learners
going um next in the automobile kind of
section we'll see how we can then take
um
spark to be able to
parallel parallelize some of our automl
trials and so in this first example we
have is we're just doing a simple
classification task and what we'll do is
we'll actually convert our spark data
frame into a pandas on spark data frame
it's basically just another wrapper kind
of another interaction that you can have
using your familiar pandas apis just on
top of the spark
but as you can see here it's still a you
know pandas Pi spark data Framing and so
then we can run automl and fit it just
on top of that pandas
pandas Pi spark data frame and here what
we'll see is that it'll go through a
list of spark based Learners and so one
of the things that on the products that
we're kind of helping contribute back to
is adding a lot more you know additional
spark based Learners to this list but
then we'll go through and kind of go
through all of the different
combinations for this automl trial and
we'll see that you know posted a bad
part
our best optimized model which has
I guess our AUC or Roc score for 0.9
degrees so again we can see some pretty
significant improvements on this data
set when using spark and
the results that we see
um so the last section of this I want to
show how we can use spark to parallelize
just run multiple trials at the same
time
and so in this example like I mentioned
we'll set our number of concurrent
trials to two
and then we'll see that um
in this case we'll go back and we'll fit
um
we'll convert this back into a pandas
data frame so that we can run the
training across all the nodes and then
here we'll have we'll just fit our
pandas data frame on our automobile
experience
okay so and then
yeah so unfortunately it is the last
three words something changed but um
once used with the stock you'll be able
to see that once you've kind of executed
the automl trial it will go through and
explore a lot of different kinds of
Learners
um so this isn't just restricted to the
spark when you're parallelizing right it
can run all your circular based Learners
um
like GPM other kinds of Frameworks and
then it'll also come back with kind of
your best model unfortunately in this
example I think the you know Book
application
but um
but then we'll kind of skip back
um
yeah so here you can see there's a lot
of different ways that you can use spark
to kind of
decide how you want to parallelize or
improve some of your execution for your
experiments
in some cases when you're doing parallel
versus sequential tuning
um parallelizing it might not be your
kind of best option this is particularly
you know highlighted when you have a lot
of
you know there's if the overhead in the
trial time for running all of these
things
um might not be worth it you might also
want to consider things like how if
you're using spark your Randomness might
get affected or the availability of even
some of your fellow resources and the
cost of these so these are also factors
that you might want to consider when
deciding when you want to parallelize or
consequentially
we have an example here we won't go
through all the math right but you can
kind of understand that depending on the
overhead time of writing multiple trials
and the different notes having to
communicate and coordinate with each
other it might not always be the most
efficient and so
um there's some kind of like rough math
that you can take a look at on how when
you might want to use some of these
kinds of features
um
but I think in the next section what
we'll Now cover is
um the next session will then cover as
well as effect to Andreas and
your features around
okay so um
we had a question earlier about
um okay how good how can I deal with
um multiple objectives and so
um there's this recent work
um which is going to be published this
year in iClear
um
by um and his collaborators
um on the target type of optimization
with external graphic objectives
so here the um
in there is that you have multiple
objectives together with the priority
ordering
so um
the most standard
is um single objective apparent
optimization which we saw before we
basically want to optimize accuracy
given a budget constraint
and what little objectives you usually
have
um
you're looking for operational front
here that's like
really hard to choose how you want to do
that
um with the setting we're looking at
here is that you have multiple
objectives with the priority order of
the objectives
so for example
um
the loss the number of features and how
stable it is
um so you can do this
um in funnel by specifying
um well the metrics
um so this is the only thing that's
really required but
um then you can also specify tolerance
and targets tolerance to say
um within how much
um
uh something should be basically
considered as optimal and the target
should be the optimization value like if
you want something to be zero or one or
five or something like that
um there's also then one repo but um I
think we're not going to go into this
since we have some other demos
but I think yeah
um
what I I want to go through in a little
bit more detail is
um tuning
um
models and
for basically
accurate and cheap inference
so here cost effective is quite literal
in that
um
most of these large language models are
behind apis and you have to pay per call
per token and so
um
we've seen that that
like the way you phrase a prompt which
model you use the temperature you use
the length you use of tokens you that
you want to predict and so on has a
pretty big impact on how accurate your
results are
and
so
similar to Senate machine learning these
you can consider like these like the
problem structure temperature and so on
as like hyper parameters that you want
to choose
um
but running these models is very
expensive and so ideally you want to
tune these type of parameters by a doing
a minimum number of queries to the model
and since they're um also
usually charged by token length you want
to use a minimum number of tokens
and so formal has this integration that
um
allows you to tune by
um or while taking these constraints
into account and specifically optimized
to work with
as a restrictive number or sorry looking
the number of tokens and limiting the
number of calls
okay
so um
I'm going to show you a demo for that
okay so for this you have to pip install
file with the open AI integration
so
you need an um
obviously to run these models you need
an open AI account or an Azure open AI
account and so here we use the Azure
open AI integration and you need to get
your API key
um
and then you use these models
we're
using the open AI human evil data set
here which is
um the python code generation task this
is a standard last language model
Benchmark task
um
The Prompt here is
the is the function name and the doc
string and we want to
um
generate code for the function
the data set contains 164 samples and if
we use the first 20 for tuning the
generation type of parameters in the
rest for evaluation
so one of the things that actually kind
of allows us to tune here is that we
have
a way to measure whether generation is
good or not in this case this is a unit
tests so in this data set we have unit
tests that check whether the function
does the right thing
in general prompting tasks that's quite
tricky
um if you can do that that makes tuning
much easier
if you don't have an auto way automated
way to check how good a prompt is it's
going to be much harder to use this
okay so here we specify
um what we
want to tune so with a lot of data set
to say we want to tune on the first at
20 points
um and
um
we're using
uh the props from the data set
and so here this is one of the prompts
where you can see there's the definition
of a function uh Dev compare game guess
and then there's
um kind of not very succinct dark string
that says you want to compare two lists
basically and give the absolute value of
the differences and the task is for
large language model to
um
write a python code that implements the
function
and then there's
um
the test cases included
let's say basically
whether the function was implemented
correctly by the model
obviously like the first test like it
needs to the python code needs to run
but also it needs to
um
evaluate this way so if you want to have
the difference the absolute difference
is between zero and zero should I put
zero and so on
um
so when you find the
um success metric success metric is that
we want to
um
um execute the code
um so we just have parenthesis run uh so
we run so sorry we get the code we write
it to a file we run it and
um unless we timeout and which or
um in case there's an error will return
zero otherwise
um
we return one if it's exceeded
and
um then we can we pronounce the test
metric as
the number of successes so here
we can
um so in many large language model tasks
you'll only want to provide a single
answer but you want to provide multiple
answers as a recommendation to the users
if you have a co-pilot like experience
you don't want to just give it one
answer you want to give provide answers
that are all possible the user can pick
from them
and so one of the success metrics that
we found works very well is that you
check not only what so the default
that's used by the Revenge Mark is you
check if any of the answers or any of
the top pay answers is good so you check
if any of them work
um
but we found for optimizations better if
you just if you see
um how many of them are successful so
your return of the number of return
things that it's a parameter how many
results you want to return
um how many of them were successful and
we try to tune that
which is different from when I said the
The Benchmark metric
um so there's this so completion tune is
um
the interface for doing the um
the tuning of any enough language models
and so
um we just initialize it and then
we Define the search space and this is
actually a
so we pick different models so there's
um
text adapt text privileged text DaVinci
E3 uh property free turbo this is check
GPT ngpt4 which is the newest model
um
then we say what parameters to tune
which is the temperature which is a
uniform 0.01
um
and if you're not familiar with it in
these larger language models low
temperature means deterministic results
high temperature means more
probabilistic results that are sort of
more creative or more like have more
variants in them and
top p is a different way to basically
specify something similar
and um
then we can specify what's the maximum
number of tokens uh that
we want to get returned this is both the
hyper parameter but also influences
strongly like how much it costs because
if you want to create more tokens at car
uh the call will be more expensive and
then n is
the number of responses you want to get
from the model again this is hyper
parameter but also
um
changes how much it costs because like
basically
N is a multiplier for the cost because
for each completion you want you have
this you have to run the model and that
will um
cost you each individually
so what's different here from Senate
automl well there's several things that
are different one is we have a separate
inference and optimization budget
and so before we had an authorization
budget which basically said Okay I want
to tune this for five minutes and then I
want to get the best mark
here we can say Okay I want to tune this
for twenty dollars and then I want to
get the best model but also
um there's an inference budget which
says
I want to model that only costs that
much
and so for example running tpp4 is much
more expensive than running gpd3 so you
could run gpt3 like I think
I forgot maybe 100 times uh instead of
running gpd4 once and so
um you specify not only how much money
do you want to spend if you're in the
model but also how much money do you
want to spend on each call of the model
during prediction time
and so you have two budgets here now
that you
um
that you specify
so here you can see the um
the the call to the tune so you have the
data the metric
we want to maximize the expected success
and we have the inference budget sorry
um which is
we want to pay five percent per
inference and we have the implementation
at the budget meaning we want to spend
three dollars optimizing to get the best
results
um
and uh we also specify
different prompts and so here
The Prompt variable or the problem
template here is what's part of the data
set so it's a function name plus the dot
string but then we also have different
uh sort of prompt engineering techniques
here where we also put something else in
front of the prompt say Python 3 or
completely following python function or
a completely full impacted function
while including necessary import
statements inside the function
um
okay then we can run it and
so
it will respect your budget constraint
it will respect the concentration for
the
um
prediction time budget
but also it will search in a way that
um
optimize the number of calls you want to
minimize the amount of money you spent
during
um during tuning obviously and so
whenever something uh looks like it will
be too expensive during prediction time
it stops early
so just basically it starts from the 20
examples that will be used for
evaluation it just first sends one and
uh looks how expensive it's going to be
to run the other ones and if it looks
like it's going to be too expensive we
will not run them and we'll pick a
different configuration if it's cheaper
so it's very aggressive in pruning the
search space to make sure that
um you don't spend too much money during
tuning and you get a cheap function or a
cheap configuration option
um
so
here you can see that after the
optimization The Prompt is completely
full and prices function so that's that
worked the best from all the Chrome
engineering
it's used text m1g2 and
um
this time with Microsoft tokens number
of
completions and temperature
and then you can use this configuration
to
do the completions on the test data
and
you can see the expected success rate is
um
37 the success which is like a top case
success
um it's 77 and the inference cost
per sample is for Cent whereas empty
um
total cost is about
7.70
any any questions on on this example
um
I want to briefly since we have quite a
bit of telephone I briefly go over
another demo of tuning a model
um
in this case it's tuning
um basically check GPT to solve the math
benchmark problems
and so this is another like last
language model Benchmark
um and dangerous to solve math problem
with
um chain of fog dial reasoning
again you obviously need to have like an
uh open my eyes subscription and have
your keys and
um
and we and again we're loading a data
set this is the
the having phase data set module is just
called data sets which is great
um
and
we take out there's like different level
of algebraic questions and we take out
one or two questions which are sort of a
little bit easier
and so here this is what they look like
the sum of different items weight
inverse weight is 180 pounds if you
subtract and it gives away from what
it's weight you get half of us weight
how many pounds does Bob weigh
foreign
question in text form
and then the solution looks something
like this which is like a mixture of
text and latex
so
um
again we need to define the success
metric that we can do automatically and
so here this is basically uh
parsing the
um
the latex to get the result I'm not
going to go through the details
um
and basically Parcels yeah so Parcels
delay tag to get out fractions in the
numbers and
all kinds of different things and then
in the end
Compares that against the
the desired answer
so this is kind of tricky because like
the output of the model is latex and the
design answer really if you want like
you want to check if the number is
correct and so but there's many
different ways you can represent the
numbers in the latex masks and so on and
so
um
you can also check if the Chain of
Thought is correct but
um I think we're not doing this here
because I would be even more complicated
okay so now we can again try to
um tune the model we're uh selecting
between two models there's a more
complicated tasks we compare the
transgender PT which is HPD 3.5 turbo
and gpd4 and if we select the
temperature and maximum tokens
and the um
n with just a number of completions
so again here we specify the inference
budget which is three cents the
optimization budget which is one dollar
um
and then you can see
the the different trials
um
and actually errored
um and so you can see that in the end
okay getting
um 50 prompts with
um 7 or 70 Max tokens and using qpt35
turbo was best so it was actually good
to get to use the cheaper modeling I
think there's more prompts than to use
the more expensive model to solve these
um
different problems
if you look at the paper you can see
that if you use a higher level algebra
problems like uh the level four I think
then you
um maybe even for level three then using
254 is better than using GPD 3.5 the
course for the more complex questions
you need a more complex model
and then for the simple question it's
basically calling the simple model more
often is more cost effective
and here's some of the problem results
and
all right
um I think this was all on tuning the
models so really the um key takeaway
here is that we can use similar
techniques to order them around but
really we can work with having these two
different constraints the inference
budget and the tuning budget and the
specific structure of the insurance
budget allows us to prune some guidance
very very quickly so we can focus on the
models that are cheap enough to actually
run production
all right so
this sort of concludes all of them with
the features we wanted to show
um
a little bit about the ongoing
development as well
so there's
um
a huge number of contributors from both
Academia and Industry so
um this is not only like a Microsoft
Project there's people from data breaks
from any scale working on this many
universities and so this is both like
Cutting Edge research and it's being
published as you saw there's um the
electrographic metrics or something
that's an oral and I clear this year but
also something that is integrated
into many products at Microsoft and
other places
and so um
this is a huge open source Community as
well so if you want to contribute uh
you're we're welcome
um there's a contribution guys online
um and roadmap for our client features
do you want to work on any of them if
you have a specific application in mind
um and you need to add features for your
applications
um
come to the issue tracker if you just go
try it out if you find bugs issues uh
let us know
you can also if you don't want to go to
the issue tracker just talk to
developers there's a Discord and
um so you can just share what are the
things you're working on
um the particularly interesting or like
the the new things like the multiple
electric graphic metrics or the tuning
large language models but if you have
any use cases for any of it
um just come on the Discord and check
with us
several things that our current
development is like more generative
tasked
improving autonomous AI along the lines
of Auto GPT
um
and improving always robustness of the
library
yeah you can find more on documentation
and GitHub
and so there's all of the
um
then what we show are should all be on
the GitHub if you can't find anything
just shoot us a message
and so
this is like the current list of papers
but new methods are being constantly
added
um
so if you want to know more I think
the original funnel paper
and it's probably one of the most more
interesting ones
um and then for the most recent work the
cost effective type of product
optimization for large language models
shows how you can provably get results
for
um that are achieved both in terms of in
first time and in terms of tuning time
sorry not the first time but in terms of
time costs and tuning time costs
um
yeah
all right everybody
[Applause]
uh you have a 30-minute break before the
next session and then also if you are
going to the hood room session at 11
o'clock that